throughout the movie there are these
foreign words that appear on the walls
that are never really explained
so if you want to hear all about the
meanings of the symbology and phrases
hidden around the film
stick around to the end of this video
with all things you missed episodes
there will be spoilers i just wanted to
emphasize this time because this film
really goes into some unexpected places
so do yourself the favor of watching the
movie before you watch this video
so with that being said wow this was a
crazy movie
i did not expect this to become a
possession film but looking back on it
the signs are all there
i even noticed a lot of the signs like
the necklace and the decapitated figures
when i did the things you missed on the
trailer way back in january but they
withheld enough information to keep us
in the dark
during the movie so let's start at the
beginning the first thing we see is a
title card letting us know about the
passing of the grandmother ellen
and it also introduces us to her
daughter annie and her granddaughter
charlie the three generations of women
are the basis for the movie's title
hereditary
or something determined by genetic
factors and therefore able to be passed
down from parents to their offspring or
descendants what is this trait being
passed down
we don't find that out until later the
first shot we see is the tree house
little do we know it's actually a chapel
of demonic worship
hear that that's the sound of the
exploding heads of everyone who didn't
take my advice to just see the movie
first
this treehouse is significant because at
the beginning of the film the family is
getting ready to head to the
grandmother's funeral service and they
can't find charlie because
she actually sleeps out in the tree
house when the mom finds her there she's
upset because apparently it's really
cold and she's worried that charlie
might catch pneumonia to which charlie
says i don't care
getting pneumonia is pretty serious
unless you're planning on ditching your
current vessel for a new body sometime
soon
based off of that the demon king paimon
is already in possession of charlie's
body at the start of the movie
possibly before she's even born her
mother tells her that she never once
cried as a baby
and that the grandmother really wanted
her to be a boy suggesting that she had
been planning to make the child into a
male vessel
befitting the demon from before
charlie's birth the doormat embroidered
by the grandma
even says charles instead of charlie at
the funeral annie gives quite a strange
eulogy for her mother
let's roll it it's heartening to see so
many
strange new faces here today i know my
mom would be very touched
and probably a little suspicious
my mother was a very secretive and
private woman
i think it's pretty clear what those
private rituals are now
knowing that she was the leader or as
they call it in this movie the queen of
a demonic cult
as for the private friend she mentioned
they are her followers
she notes that the faces who show up to
the funeral are not familiar and that is
probably why
in fact i think the naked people who
appear in the house towards the end of
the movie
a24 loves their creepy naked old people
don't they
are probably some of the same people who
show up at the service though i would
have no way of confirming this until i
have a copy of the movie so don't chop
my head off if that doesn't end up being
true
also if anyone can find joan in the
crowd somewhere tweet me a picture of it
yeah
i believe it was as they're leaving the
funeral when we see charlie eating a
chocolate bar and chocolate can be
associated with the devil
it's the devil's temptation that's why
you have devil's food cake which is the
chocolate one an angel's food cake which
is
not the chocolate one i'm pretty sure
chocolate is the only thing we see her
eat
first this chocolate bar and second the
chocolate cake at the party
side note i absolutely love how she eats
the chocolate like mellow from death
note
i was smiling to myself in the theater
when i saw that i also dug the red
doorknob i think it was on peter's room
or possibly charlie's and that's a
reference to the sixth sense
it could be that the red doorknob was
used in a similar way to indicate the
presence of spirits
so i found that to be an interesting
parallel because the two films do share
a lot of similarities
so the family gets home from the funeral
and they're all dealing with grief in
their own ways
annie recreates moments from her
mother's life using her miniatures
so what's the meaning behind the
miniatures here's my interpretation
it has to do with one of the traits
that's passed down in the family
manipulation
starting at the top king paiman
manipulates ellen into leading the cult
that worships him
by offering to make her his queen in
turn ellen manipulates the entire family
annie steve charlie and peter are all
her pawns in her plot to resurrect king
paimon
she's orchestrating all of the pieces
that lead to king paimon getting into
his intended body
peter's body annie is subconsciously at
king paiman's will as well but her mind
is strong enough to resist him at least
for the time being that's why he's only
able to control her subconscious
the reason she finds herself on the
verge of burning up her son while
sleepwalking and the reason she finds
herself creating miniature versions of
the tragic events that lead up to the
body transfer
her manipulation of the miniature
figures represents her mother's
manipulation of the actual household
but it doesn't stop there because
charlie is also into arts and crafts
making her own miniature figures and
idols and eventually making the
life-size king
paimon idol that we see at the end of
the movie she doesn't seem to have any
other interest
outside of creating these demented
figures she's doing sketches at the
funeral
modifying some toy during class and
cutting up a dead bird at recess
so this manipulation is a trait that
runs all the way down the family line
and it seems to be passed to all of the
females
i also did a little reading on king
paimon and apparently he has a flair for
the arts
and people like to call on him to assist
with their creative projects which is
why annie and charlie display their
traits through their craft
as we get later into the movie annie's
mind gets weaker and weaker
annie works less on the model for her
work and more on personal pieces
representing the family because she'll
soon be a pawn of king paimon like her
mother before her
as peter's class might put it in a
discussion about the flaws of greek
mythological figure heracles
the characters are all just pawns in
this horrible hopelessness
i think that stands for the movie
hereditary as well ellen obviously
doesn't see it that way because
she leaves a note for annie essentially
apologizing for what's happened so far
and what's about to happen
but saying that these sacrifices must be
made and everything will be good in the
end
i'm paraphrasing here but she's
basically outlining her plan to tear
apart the family with tragedy so that
she can become the queen and they can
join the cult of paimon
this begins before her death at the
first group meeting that annie goes to
to try to ease her grief she talks a
little bit about her family history
and mentions that her mom has did and
dementia did if you don't know is short
for dissociative identity disorder
commonly referred to as multiple
personality disorder
i don't think she really has this
disorder though it would make a lot of
sense if she was starting to lose
control to king paimon making it appear
that she was switching personalities
if that's the case it could also help
explain her dementia not much background
is given on the rest of the family but
we know that annie's father starved
himself and her brother committed
suicide which brings me to the second
trait that is passed down in hereditary
though it's not so much as the trait as
it is a commonality
that they all suffer tragic deaths you
have to believe that king paimon is
somehow involved in carrying that out
this all comes to a head with charlie at
13 she should be old enough to check
anything she eats in regards to her food
allergy but something causes her to eat
that cake anyways
and just when it looks like peter might
be able to rush her to the hospital in
time
she sticks her head out the window and
gets decapitated by the pole on the side
of the road
but this is no accident it's all part of
ellen and king paimon's plan
decapitation seems to somehow be a
requirement for the cult because we see
the same thing happen to the bodies of
ellen
and annie if you need any further proof
the symbol of king paimon can be seen on
that
same poll as peter and charlie head to
the party nearly
everything that the demon has
manipulated has this symbol it's on
annie and ellen's necklaces
in jones house after she's placed the
curse on annie and
written in blood on the roof of the
attic where ellen's body is stored
when we see the king at the end the idol
also wears that symbol
i already mentioned how one of peter's
classmates has the onpoint heracles
analysis
well in another class he's learning
about the great depression you can see
it written on the chalkboard and how it
was started by the great crash
which was when the stock market crashed
in 1929.
you could say the same about the family
in the movie though that a great
depression was cast over them after
a great crash after that depression sets
in the demon with the help of ellen's
secret friend joan
starts to take over the family in order
to get to the body that he wants
joan pretends to befriend annie at the
support group so that she can ease her
into the idea of performing the ritual
the summon king paimon
she is almost given away by her doormat
which was made by annie's mother who
embroidered the doormats for the
grandkids
but annie ends up brushing it off as
just a similar style
eventually annie does find out that joan
and ellen were in cahoots all she had to
do was look in her mother's left behind
photo album but their relationship was
so bad that ellen didn't even have to
worry about her daughter finding out
in fact it's mentioned that they were
practically estranged until the birth of
charlie when ellen suddenly started to
take interest for obvious reasons
she had plans for charlie suddenly all
the weird stuff from early on
starts to make more sense how charlie
was her grandmother's favorite child
how annie kept ellen away from peter but
quote gave charlie to her
how annie wasn't even allowed to
breastfeed her own daughter because
she needed to feed you and how charlie
wondered who would be taking care of her
now that ellen was gone
but as annie starts to figure out what's
going on she begins to lose herself to
the fate destined by her dna
all of a sudden she can only get sleep
in the tree house which as a reminder is
a freezing cold demon worship site
fights break out at the dinner table
annie accuses peter of
looking at her with that face on his
face all i do
is worry and all i get back is that face
on your face
possible reference to the fact that he
is not destined to possess his own body
also after the death of charlie we start
to see this light flare occasionally
come up i believe this strange light is
the physical manifestation of king
paimon when he's not inside of a body
we see it stalk peter in the hall at
school where he ends up temporarily
losing himself to king paimon smashing
his face against the desk then it comes
up after the father
steve bursts into flames suggesting that
it's traveling from one body to another
then near the end when peter commits
suicide by jumping out the window the
light travels
lands on him then disappears when
peter's body reawakes he's taken over by
king paimon he goes to his new place of
worship the treehouse where the movie
ends with many voices
chanting the name of the king of hell
there are only like six people in the
treehouse and half of them are beheaded
but it sounds like 20 or more voices
chanting which created a creepy effect
that actually sounded like the audience
members in front of me were chanting too
so that covers everything that i noticed
in the movie except for the strange
words
written on the wall throughout the movie
we know that they're not english and
they're likely the same language that
joan made annie recite the ritual spell
in
here are four words that i noticed i
couldn't find much info
on satany other than the fact that it's
used as a word to summon a demon and it
sounds kind of similar to satan
zazas is similar to zaza or zozo which
is part of a supposed phenomenon among
ouija board users where upon
asking who they are speaking to the
board would spell out z-a-z-a
or z-o-z-o i was only able to find a
couple sources online talking about lift
touch
but i guess it's a rough english
spelling of a hebrew word leaf toe which
means open
and it was used in this one black metal
song called dissection by rain chaos
where the full line translated to blind
dragon open your eyes
could have something to do with those
pictures of peter with his eyes crossed
out and then the last one is pandemonium
an english word meaning wild and noisy
disorder and it also contains the word
demon inside of it
alright there was a lot to take in with
this movie so drop me a comment and let
me know what you noticed
and if you enjoyed this movie let me
know by giving this video a like
this has been a crazy week if you're a
horror fan of new movies new trailers
just yesterday i put out 28 things you
missed in the halloween trailer so make
sure you check that out if you haven't
seen it yet i'm going to be keeping you
up to date on all the new things you
missed so remember to subscribe to cz's
world for new horrors
every week ring that death bell for
notifications
and i'll see you in the next one
assuming
we both survive